اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
روسيا تتوعد برد صارم على هجماته واعلامها
ينشر صورا لمركبات يقول انها امريكيه
اقتحمت المدينه
ومتعاقد جندهم لحسم معركه بخمول
وتجدد الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله شمال
الخرطوم بحري وعدد نازحين داخل يتجاوز
المليون
[موسيقى]
ورئيس
للاجئين يعلن دعمه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
توعد وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو برد
صارم على اي محاولات لتوغل مسلحين
اوكرانيين للحدود الروسيه مشيرا الى مقتل
سبعين مسلحا في بيلجورون
هذا ونشرت وسائل اعلام روسيه مقاطع مصوره
قالت انها لمركبات امريكيه الصنع استخدمها
المسلحون الاوكرانيون في الهجوم على منطقه
بيلجورون الحدوديه
وذكرت التقارير الروسيه ان المواجهات
تسببت في تضرر خمسمائه منزل على الاقل في
[موسيقى]
روسيا كانت قد تصدت لهجوم بالمسيرات
الاوكرانيه بينما لفه كييف ضلوعها بالهجوم
فما الذي حدث في المنطقه الروسيه المحاذيه
بالقرون
فقد اعلنت مجموعه من الروس المناهضين
للكرملين والمتحالفين مع الجيش الاوكراني
مسؤوليتهم عن الهجوم بعد ان سيطروا على
نقطه حدوديه بحسب شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
وفي الوقت الذي ادانا فيه المسؤولون الروس
الهجوم لاحظ المحللون ارتباكا واسعا نطاق
في الفضاء المعلوماتي الروسي حول كيفيه
تنفيذ الهجوم وكيف ينبغي لموسكو الرد
ومن غير المرجح بحسب محللين ان تؤدي
الهجمات هذه الى التحول في الزخم في الحرب
الاوسع في اوكرانيا التي تركزت بشكل كبير
في المناطق الشرقيه للبلاد
من هم المقاتلون المتسللون الى روسيا من
اوكرانيا
موسكو تقول انه مسلحون اوكرانيون
بينما كيف تفيد بانه مسلحون ينتمون الى
مجموعتين شبه عسكريتين مناهضتين للكريم
مسؤولون اوكرانيون يوضحون ان الفيلق حريه
روسيا يتضمن مواطنين روسا يسعى الى انشاء
منطقه امنيه للاوكرانيين
فيلق المتطوعين الروسي يعرف زعيمه باسم
دينيس كابوستيل
يعتنق علنا ايديولوجيه دوله روسيه احاديه
العرق
فيلق حريه روسيا يقاتل الى جانب القوات
الاوكرانيه ضد نظيرتها الروسيه
يرفع ما يعتبره على ما روسيا الحره واعتبر
نفسه جزءا من المعارضه الروسيه
اخر المعلومات تشير الى قصف اوكراني عنيف
على ضواحي خركيف هنا السؤال المشهد
الميداني كيف يبدو
والى اي مدى هذا صحيح يعني وما الذي
يستهدفه هذا القصف
مساء الخير طالب بالفعل منذ دقائق يعني
اعلنت الوكالات الرسميه
والتلفزه الروسيه مشاهد لاثار القصف
الاوكراني حسب المصدر بان بعض من القذائف
سقطت على مدينه
يعني تسببت باضرار في الابنيه في المركبات
والسيارات في الشوارع لكن لم يسفر هذا
القصف عن ضحايا او اصابات حتى الان ومنذ
الصباح الباكر والقوات الروسيه ايضا تقصف
مواقع عسكريه في ضواحي مقاطعه خاركب
المتاخمه
لمقاطعه بيل جراد الروسيه بالفعل تشهد هذه
المنطقه تطورات كبيره منذ اليومين
الماضيين حيث تسلل
المجموعات الارهابيه كما وصفتها موسكو
وسيطرتها على نقطه حدوديه كما اسلفت اظهرت
صور على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هذه
الصور لسيطره القوات او
مقاتلين الاوكرانيين على هذه النقطه
الحدوديه لكن الجيش الروسي تعامل معهم
يعني
النحا حوالي سبعين مقاتل ويعني لاحق
الفارين والحديث عن انه قتلهم ايضا بالفعل
ماذا زالت المنطقه ساخنه حتى الان حيث
القصف المتبادل ما بين الطرفين وهناك ايضا
يعني مداخله او تعليق من
قائد قوات فاجنر بخصوص بيليق يقول ينتقد
كالعاده الدفاع الروسيه يقول بانه عرض على
الدفاع الروسيه انشاء قواعد عسكريه لفاغنر
لتدريب المستجدين ولحمايه المقاطعه لكنهم
طلبوا منه ان لا يتدخل رائد انت وفق
متابعتك انت وفق متابعتك رائد لماذا لماذا
بيل جرود لماذا الان تحريك هذه الجبهه
ما هي اهميه بالجرود
هو هناك يعني شقين من الاجابه على هذا
السؤال الشق الاول ان الجانب الاوكراني
يريد لفت النظر عن ما يحدث في باقمته عن
خسارتهم هكذا يعني المحللون الرسل يقولون
بان الجانب الاوكراني يريد ابعاد الضوء
تسليط الضوء لا يكون على باخ متوا وانتصار
روسيا في باخمت وتسليط الضوء على
يعني مساله او صراع يصب في صالح القوات
الاوكرانيه والمساله الثانيه هو ان
المنطقه حدوديه وهناك تمركز كبير قواعد
عسكريه كبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه ويمكنها
ان يعني تضرب او يعني تصيب
الخاصره الضعيفه للجانب الروسي وهي منطقه
ضعيفه بالامدادات العسكريه لعدم توقع
روسيا بان الجيش الاوكراني يمكن ان يتدخل
في العمق الروسي ولا ولا يكمل معاركه على
ارا ضي الصراع في الازمه الاوكرانيه ان
كان في الشرق او في الجنوب لكن لا سمح لنا
الوقت
القائم باعمال الرئاسه هنا قال بان المحور
الجنوبي والجنوبي الغربي تم السيطره عليه
حيث كان التمدد الاوكراني والمعارك
الضاريه في ذلك المحور قال بانه جيش
الروسي سيطر على هذا المحور والاوضاع هناك
هادئه الان بعد ان دفع الجيش الروسي
القوات الاوكرانيه للانسحاب من هذا المحور
العربيه للاسف رائد دائما الوقت يدعمنا
منذ ان العربي شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على كل
هذه المتابعه
الناطقه باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريه زخرفه قالت ان الولايات المتحده
تخشى الاعتراف بها كدوله تشارك في الصراع
في اوكرانيا وليست فقط كمراقب او وسيط
فيها
واعتبرت زخرفه ان زعما واشنطن بانها لا
تشجع ضربات اوكرانيه ضد الاراضي الروسيه
ياتي كي لا تنكشف حقيقه استخدامها كوسيله
لتلبيه مصالحها الخاصه
واتهمت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
واشنطن بصنع الازمه الاوكرانيه حسب
تعبيرها
على صعيد اخر قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني
ان بلاده قدمت اسلحه متطوره الى كييف من
شانها ضربات في عمق الدفاعات الروسيه
احدث سلاحا قدمته بريطانيا لاوكرانيا هو
صاروخ ستورم شادو وهو بامكانه شن الضربات
في عمق الدفاعات الروسيه واول صاروخ بعيد
المدى يتم تزويد اوكرانيا به من الحلفاء
قمنا بذلك بسبب استخدام روسيا المستمر
لاسلحتها بعيده المدى لاستهداف المدنيين
والبنيه التحتيه الحيويه المدنيه بما
يتعارض مع القانون الدولي واتفاقيات جنيف
يجب ان تتيقن روسيا من ان حلفاء اوكرانيا
سوف يقفون الى جانبها للدفاع عن نفسها
وسيقدمون اي دعم تحتاجه من الصواريخ
المضاده للدبابات وغيرها من الصواريخ مثل
طائرات اف 16
وفي المقابل قال الامين العام لحلف الناتو
يانس اليوم ان اوكرانيا لن تتمكن من
الانضمام الى الحلف ما دامت الحرب مستمره
وقال الصولنبرد اثناء ندوه لصندوق مارشال
الالماني بدروكسل ان الجميع في حلف الناتو
يدركوا الانضمام اوكرانيا قبل انتهاء
الحرب ليس في اجندتنا وان النقاش في هذا
الامر يمكن ان يبدا بعد نهايه الحرب
مينياب ينضم اليه لمزيد من المتابعه
والتحليل ماكسيميالي وهو استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه الطيران الوطنيه سيد
مكسيما اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشره الخامسه
وزير الدفاع الروسي توعد برد حازم وصارم
على هجوم ما الذي تتوقعونه من رد روسي
القوي سبق وان حصل قبل الهجوم ضد
هو لم يكن هجوما بل مجموعه من المواطنين
الروس
الذين اخترقوا دخلوا
اما فيما يخص الحاجه الروسيه فخلال
الاسبوع الماضي او حتى قبل عشره ايام منذ
بدايه مايو
والصواريخ والمسيارات ازدادت بشده خاصه
على كياب في كل يوم يطلقون صواريخ كبيره
من ضمنها حتى
الطرطه الصوتيه التي
اسقطناها يوم الاثنين الماضي بمساعده
منظومات الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه الباتريوت
وفي كل يوم
اذا ما اردنا ان نقارن قبل هذا الشهر
فقد استولى على كافه المناطق الاوكرانيه
بهجومه الصواريخ والمسيرات اذا هم
بداوا هذه الهجمات وحاولوا
التحدي المنظمه الدفاع الاوكرانيه التي
منحتنا اياها حلفائنا الروس وقت بذلك خاصه
من اجل ردع عملياتنا للهجوم المضاده والتي
قمنا باعدادها والتي هي على وشك ان تبدا
عن قريب
تماما كما ذكر القائد المخابرات العسكري
استخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه فعندما ذكر
في مقابلته قبل بضعه ايام اذن
شهدنا هذا التصعيد كما ذكرت
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين في كافه ارجاء
اوكرانيا
ليس لديهم ما يكمل الاحتياطي لشني عمله
نجوميه على الارض او الميدان وبالتالي هم
يستخدمون
وهنالك كلمه لرئيس الروسي
وكذلك
ان بناء مثل هذه
الطرق ستبدا
في هذا العام
وتجري ويجري العمل
بالتعاون كبير مع اذربيجان ونحن نعول على
توقيع الوثائق ضمن في ضمن اطار ثلاثي
بمشاركه الجانب الاذري
واقصد هنا
تطوير السكك الحديد
والشحن في الممر الشمالي الجنوبي وان
اطلاق هذا الممر سيسمح
بالترانزيت عام سنويا حتى 30,000 طن 30
مليون طن عفوا وهذا
يعزز الطرق التجاريه التقليديه ويساعد على
ظهور مراكز صناعيه وتجاريه جديده على طول
هذا الخط وهذا سيؤمن كذلك الاف الاماكن
العمل في سائر الفضاء الاوراثي وسوف تتغير
بشكل جذري
المنظومه الماليه وهنا اود ان اشير برضا
عن ان روسيا ليس لم تتاقلم فحسب بل اقامه
باتخاذ مسار
لتقليل التعامل المالي مع الدول غير
الصديقه
وزياده هذا التعاون مع دول اخرى من خلال
الانتقال الى التعامل في العملات الوطنيه
والكثير من الدول
ايضا تسعى لهذا
التعامل بالعملات الوطنيه بما في ذلك
الهند والصين
وهذا يعني
اقامه
منظومه ماليه غير مركزيه ولا تعتمد على
عنصر محدد وانما ستكون
كلما كانت غير مركزيه كل ما كانت افضل ولن
تكون معتمده او تتضرر
بالتهديدات الجيوب سياسيه ولا
تمتلك
اي تهديدات
للاحتياطيات الماليه وهذا سيجعل
العمل في المجال الاقتصادي غير مسيس نحن
دائما ندعم المبادرات
من قبل
ممثلي العمل بما في ذلك اطلاق
شركات التامين القرص الاوراسيه التي سوف
تساعد في
سواء في الفضاء الاوراسي وغيره من وغيرها
من الدول وكذلك سيكون هناك ساحه كبيره
لتبادل الخبراء الخبرات بين رجال الاعمال
وستمكن من ايجاد مناهج ومواقف مختلفه
للمشاريع المشاركه ومن المهام الاوليه
للاتحاد الاوروبي هو الحفاظ على الاقتصاد
السياده
الاقتصاديه
وهذا يعني ان لدينا كل الكوادر
والامكانيات
للحفاظ على المنافسه في الاقتصاد العالمي
وهذه من اهم نقاط
حتى يومنا هذا اي
الحصول على الاستقلال
التقني
وهذا سيؤدي بحد ذاته الى الاستقلال
الاقتصادي
والسياسي اضافه الى ذلك لابد من تحضير
المتخصصين والكوادر والتي تعتبر ضروره
كبيره من خلال تطوير البرامج التعليميه
سواء باستخدام
المنظومات التعليميه او استخدام قدرات
التعليميه الاخرى مثل المكتبات الموجوده
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وكل
الجهود
تسير في تطوير سائر المنطقه الاوراسيه
فنحن نقوم اليوم بالتعامل مع
الصين بشكل وثيق وان المبادره التي قدمتها
الصين
طريق واحد حزام واحد
ستساعد في بناء
ما يسمى
بالتعاون في الكامل والشامل في الفضاء
الاوراسي
اضافه الى التعاون مع الدول القريبه من
المنطقه الاوراسيه سواء في
الشرق وفي افريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وهي
تعتبر غالبيه
نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه الرئيس الروسي
اعزائي المشاهدين هذه المشاهد تردنا الان
لاستهداف مسيره في مضيق البوسفور
بمسيارات اوكرانيه اذا هذه المشاهد تردنا
الان لاستهداف هذه
المسيره هذه المدمره بمسيرات اوكرانيه في
مضيق
البوسفور بالطبع هنالك صور ايضا للناطق
باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ولكن هذه الاصابه مباشره لهذه
المدمره حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التصدي لهجوم بحري شنته ثلاث زوارق
اوكرانيه سريعه مسيره على سفينه ايفان
خورس التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود في
منطقه مضيق البوسفور وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ايغور انه تم تدمير جميع القوارب
عاديه في زمن قياسي مشيرا الى ان السفينه
الروسيه كانت تقوم بحمايه خطيه غاز في
المنطقه الاقتصاديه التركيه واكد ان
السفينه اذا خورس التابعه لاسطول البحر
الاسود تواصل اداء مهامها اذا الناطق باسم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه واكد ان المدمره لم
تصب باي اذى وانه جرى تدمير هذه الزوارق
المسيره بوقت سريع وفعال
في موضوع اخر تجددت الاشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله شمال الخرطوم بحري وتحدث شهود
وعيان عن سقوط طائره حربيه في ام درمان
بالسودان المفاوضه السامي للامم المتحده
لحقوق الانسان فولكر تورك قال ان اتفاقات
وقف اطلاق النار لا يتم احترامها كما اشار
الى تعرض المدنيين للخطر
ما يحدث في السودان لا امر مفجع على الرغم
من اتفاقات وقف اطلاق النار المتتاليه
فاننا نرى انه يتم خرقها في غضون ساعات
نرى كيف يستمر تعرض المدنيين لخطر الموت
والاصابه يعني بين عشيه وضحاها تلقينا
تقارير عن طائرات مقاتله عبر الخرطوم
واشتباكات في بعض مناطق المدينه وكذلك
سماع اطلاق النار في شمال الخرطوم وفي ام
درمان
اهلا وسهلا بك مجددا جديد المشهد الميداني
في الخرطوم والجوار والى ماذا يمكن القول
ان اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار انهار تماما ام
لا يعني ما زالت يعني بعض الالتزام بهذا
الاتفاق
اهلا بك طالب واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام نعم
طالب منذ صباح الباكر تجدد الاشتباكات في
عدد من المناطق كانت هذه الاشتباكات خفيفه
ولكن مع فتره الظهيره اصبحت هذه
الاشتباكات عنيفه في عدد من المناطق خاصه
في شمالي مدينه بحري في منطقه الكادرو وفي
مدينه ام درمان حيث تم تداول الفيديو
لسقوط طيار وسقوط الطائره
هذا الفيديو انتشر بكثافه في وسائط
التواصل الاجتماعي وايضا كذلك تداولته
الاخبار ايضا هنا في شرق العاصمه الخرطوم
قبل ساعه او اكثر تم اشتباك في منطقه
المنشيه ومناطق بوري اللاماب وعدن او عدد
ايضا كذلك من الشوارع المحازيه لهذه
المنطقه باعتبارها تطول على منطقه القياده
العامه للجيش من الجانب الشرقي ومطار
الخرطوم ايضا في منطقه الشجره الخرطوم
ايضا قبل دقائق تحدثنا الى مصادر ميداليه
الى
تدور في هذه المنطقه باعتبارها ايضا انها
منطقه تقود بشكل مباشر الى سلاح المدرعات
التابعه للجيش السوداني وسط
طالب كنا نستمع قبل لحظات من الدخول لهذا
المباشر الى دوري
وايضا كذلك نشاهد تصاعد لاعمده الدخان في
هذه المنطقه ما يعني انك عدد من المناطق
هنا في شرق العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مدينه
بحري وفي مدينه ام درمان وجنوب العاصمه
الخرطوم ايضا كذلك عادت اليها الاشتباكات
العنيفه
نعم باختصار موضوع موضوع النزوح واللجوء
الداخلي كيف يمكن رصده يعني انت عندما
تجول يعني هل يعني يمكن تلمس موضوع النزوح
واللجوء في الداخل السوداني
السفريات
جدا من الاهالي هنا في الشرقيه العاصمه
الخرطوم باعتبار ان الحرب دخلت في شهرها
الثاني وعدد من الخدمات تنقطع بشكل واضح
وكبير وهنالك شحو في عدد كبير من السلع
الغذائيه وايضا كذلك خدمات الكهرباء
والماء هنا تتذبذب القطاع وعوده بين فتره
واخرى ايضا كذلك هذا يرتبط بالجانب الصحي
باعتبار كثير جدا من المستشفيات خارج
الخدمه عدد من المراكز الصحيه تعمل ولكن
بشكل جزئي ايضا كذلك هذا يرتبط بالوضع
الامني
العاملات السلب والنهب او السطو اصبحت
كثيره جدا وحتى حالات الاختفاء هناك كثير
من المفقودين الاهالي يبحثون عن ابنائهم
عن اشقائهم يبحثون عنهم بشكل واضح حين
ذهبوا الطوال
ليس هنالك وجود للشرطه في عدد من المجمعات
السكانيه باعتبار ان هذه
ومناطق ساخنه جدا ولكن كل هذه المجريات
حتى الان ننتظر ان يتم تعليق من
اعلان جده حتى توضيح ماذا سيتم طالما ان
هنالك خروقات بشكل واضح جراء اليوم الثاني
من اعلان جده الذي
اكتفي بهذا القدر من الخرطوم عمار ابو
شيبه الصوت يتقطع من عندك عمار شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل على كل هذه المتابعه
اذا شهد السودان نزوحا داخليا لاكثر من
مليون شخص وفق احدث معطيات نشرتها منظمه
الهجره الدوليه واشارت المنظمه في تقرير
بهذا الخصوص الا انه منذ اندلاع الحرب في
البلاد في ابريل الماضي استقبلت ولاياته
غرب دارفور والنيل الابيض ونهر النيل
والولايات الشماليه العدد الاكبر من
النازحين
معي عبر سكايب الان من نيروبي كارلش كمبري
وهو المتحدث باسم المجلس النرويجي للاجئين
في شرق افريقيا سيد كارل اهلا وسهلا بك
الى نشاط الخامس من العربيه اكثر من مليون
نازح او لاجئ في الداخل السوداني من يتابع
اوضاعهم وما هو تقييمكم لهذا الملف الشائك
الصعوبه لاننا شهدنا هؤلاء المليون نازح
منذ اكثر من شهر ونحن بصفتنا عمل انسانيين
بالكاد تمكنا من تقديم الاستجابه وهذا امر
مزعج جدا ومشين
لانه تستمر هذه العمليات على الرغم من
وقفه الاقنار المزعوم ولسنا قادرين على
الوصول اليهم بسبب عمليات القتال في جنين
بشكل خاص وكذلك في الخرطوم وكذلك هنالك
المعوقات البيروقراطيه التي تقف في وجهنا
فلا الحصول على تاشيرات الدخول لارسال
عمرنا على الدوليين مجد عن المساعده الى
السكان المحليين وزملائنا ايضا من اجل
تعزيز استجابتنا لتقدم مساعدات وليس امكان
الوصول الى التمويل الحصول عليه من اجل
حشد اموالنا وايصال الضروريه جدا مثل الغ
ذاء والمياه واي نوع من المساعدات
الضروريه الان نحن لا نستطيع فعل ذلك
كما ان هنالك انواع عديده من المساعدات
المتجمده في بورت السودان وكل ذلك بسبب
معوقات البيروقراطيه
ابرز احتياجات هؤلاء وهل هنالك وعود او
خطط لاعادتهم الى مناطقهم الى منازلهم ام
لا حتى الساعه لا وجود لمثل هكذا خطب
نا نتحدث عن العوده الى المنازل بينما
المنزل يحتله مسلحون او يقصف بشكل مستمر
او حتى مجرد الخروج الى الشوارع
بلا شك هذا ليس بالشيء الذي يفكر فيه
الكثيرون الان قم بالتاكيد يعملون العوده
قريبا ولكن لا شيء يشير الى امكانيه عوده
اي احد خاصه الى الخرطوم التي شهدت قتالا
شديدا وقطعت عنها المياه والكهرباء واسعار
المواد الغذائيه ارتفعت بشكل كبير وكذلك
السكان حاربوا من هذه المناطق وهم مستمرون
بالفرار وهنالك الملايين من العالقين هناك
هنالك مليون نازح ولكن علينا ان لا ننسى
هؤلاء الذين يرغبون بالمغادره ولكنهم لا
يستطيعون اسباب عديده فالقتال يصعب عليهم
ذلك كما ان هنالك مسنين لا يستطيعون حتى
طويله وهنالك معاقين او حتى فقراء لا
يستطيعون الدفع تكلفه الحافلات لمناطق
بعيده الوضع بائس جدا وبصفحتنا عامه
الانسانيين ايدينا مقيده الى ان يسمحوا
لنا بالقيام بعملنا كما نتمنى ابرز
احتياجات
هؤلاء الاحتياجات الاساسيه
الضروريه بشكل اساسي هي
المياه مياه الشربه الصالحه مشكله كبيره
جدا في الخرطوم العاصمه ولم يكن احد قبل
شهرين اما الان فنحن نتحدث عن المنازل ليس
لديها الماء وكذلك المواد الغذائيه لان
اسعارها ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا والكثيرون
لا يستطيعون تحمل ثمنها
وحتى الوقود وحتى الماوى يجب ان نتدخل الى
جانب الامم المتحده والوكالات الاخرى من
اجل مساعده النازحين الذين ليس لديهم مكان
ليناموا فيها والماوى ونوفر لهم بعض
المساعده في مناطق مجتمعيه هو مخيمات
النازحين الى ان تحل هذه المشكله ولكننا
بعيدون جدا عن
تحقيق احتياجاتهم على الارض عبر سكايب
مينا روبي كارش كان بالريال المتحدث باسم
المجلس النرويجي اللاجئين في شرق افريقيا
شكرا جزيلا لك هذه المشاركه
نشاطها الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
باكستان تدرس حظر حزب عمران خان حركه
الانصاف
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعلن زعيم حزب الظفر
دعمه لمرشح المعارضه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو
خلال الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات وقال
اوداك المناهض لبقاء اللاجئين انه توصل مع
كليتش دار اوغلو على توافق في عدد كبير
القضايا لذلك قرر دعمه
هذا ويواصل الناخبون الاتراك المقيمون في
الخارج الادلاء باصواتهم في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
وقد تجاوز عدد من ادلب اصواتهم المليون
وسبعمائه الف حتى يوم امس في الممثليات
الخارجيه والمعابر الحدوديه ومن المقرر ان
تنتهي عمليه التصويت في الممثليات
الخارجيه اليوم فيما تستمر في المعابر
الحدوديه يوم الثامن والعشرين من مايو
منع القضاء اللبناني حاكم المصرف المركزي
رياض سلامه من السفر بعد استجوابه سلامي
كان مثل اليوم امام المحامي العام
التمييزي في بيروت واستمرت الجلسه ساعه
وعشرين دقيقه
المحامي العام جوازي سفر حاكم مصرف لبنان
الفرنسي واللبناني وتركه
رهن التحقيق الى ذلك اجتمع القنصل
الالماني صباح اليوم بالنائب العام
التمييزي القادر عويدات ووضعه في صوره
مذكره التوقيف الالمانيه الصادره بحق سلام
في الموازات تقدم وكلاء الحاكم القانونيون
في فرنسا بطعن امام القضاء الفرنسي
لاسترداد مذكره التوقيف الفرنسيه
المعممه عبر النشره الحمراء
على كل لمزيد من المتابع ينضم اليه الان
من بيروت مراسل العربيه محمود شكر هو يقف
امام قصر العدل في العاصمه اللبنانيه
محمود اهلا وسهلا بك هل كانت هنالك اي
مفاجات في ملف استجواب سلامي اليوم محمود
ام لا ما جرى كان متوقعا وبالتالي لم
تتغير الوضعيه القانونيه لسلام في في
لبنان بمعنى انه سيكمل عمله كالمعتاد برغم
حجز جوازي سفره
الذي شارك كما كان متوقعا على المستويين
الاعلامي الذي ايضا شرحت المصادر بالامس
ماذا ستجري عليه الامور عصر هذا اليوم هذه
من الجهه الاعلاميه اما ايضا من الجهه
القانونيه فالكل كان يقول الى ان المساله
ستذهب بعمليه ان سيترك رهن التحقيق وعليه
ان الذي جرى بعد الساعه وعشرين دقيقه هو
ان الاصول الدبلوماسيه والقضائيه كما وصل
الملف الى العاصمه بيروت الان وبعد نصف
ساعه ستبدا عمليات العوده الى فرنسا من
هنا من القصر العدل الى وزاره العدل ثم
بعد ذلك الى الخارجيه اللبنانيه الخارجيه
اللبنانيه بدورها الى الخارجيه الفرنسيه
التي ايضا بدورها الى الدوائر القضائيه
الفرنسيه ماذا قال الحاكم المصادر تتحدث
الى انه نفى كل التهم التي وجهت اليه عبر
القضاء الفرنسي واعتبرها انها غير قانونيه
لا بالشكل ولا مضمون وكما عزيزي الطالب
الى ان محاميه كانوا ظهرا في فرنسا قدموا
طعنا بهذه المساله وانه قال ان كل الذي
اتى في عمليه المذكره التبليغ من اوراق
واستنادات ودلائل القانونيه لا قيمه له
بالنسبه اليه قانونيا بالشكل او بالنون
فعليه كما اراجا في الرقه قصر العدل هو
يريد ان ارادوا المحاكمه له ان تكون
المحاكمه له داخليا في لبنان وليس خارج
يعني محمود يمكن القول يمكن القول فقط
لنفهم لنفهم المشاهدين ان القبائل
اللبناني لم ولن يستجيب لمذكرات التوقيف
الدوليه بحق سلامي واخرها المذكره
الالمانيه هل يمكن قول ذلك
باختصار
نعم القضاء اللبناني سيطلب من القضاء
الفرنسي بهذه المراسله التي ستتم اليوم
استرداد الملف باكمله بمعنى ما هي الادله
التي بنى عليها القضاء هذه المذكره وهذا
التوقيف وهذه الاتهامات اذا كانت هذه
التهم ذات الدلالات واضحه وصريحه ويبنى
عليها سيستكمل القضاء اللبناني بعمليه
المتابعه والتي ستتحول من الاستماع له الى
بعد ذلك المحاكمه اما اذا كانت براي بعض
اهل القانون لا تحتمل الكثير من الادله
الواضحه القضاء اللبناني هو في حل من امره
اما ان يستكمل التحقيق بهذه القضيه على
الطريق نقض الفرنسي واما ان يحفظه
بالاضافه ايضا الى انه هنالك
القضاء اللبناني
للحاكم له ملف سيبدا في 15 الشهر القادم
هو
توازي مع هذا الملف ولكن لا علاقه
ارتباطيه تنظيميه قانونيه ما بين ساكتفي
بهذا القدر من بيروت مراسل العربيه محمود
شكر شكرا جزيلا لك محمود على كل هذه
المتابعه
تدرس باكستان حظر حزب حركه الانصاف الذي
يراسه رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان وفق
ما اعلن وزير الدفاع الباكستاني خواجه اسف
وقال اسف ان حضر الحزب ياتي على خلفيه
مهاجمه منشات للجيش ومؤسسات للدوله وكانت
الشرطه الباكستانيه قد القت القبض على خان
في التاسع من مايو بتهم فساد ما دفع
انصاره لتنظيم احتجاجات واسعه في البلاد
قبل ان يحصل امرا خان على افراج مؤقت
بكفاله ماليه
وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد بابر اعوان احد
ابرز اعضاء الفريق القانوني لعمران خان ان
كل القضايا التي يتجاوز عددها ال105 ضد
عمران خان لا اساس لها
هناك اكثر من 145 قضيه حتى الان ضد عمران
خان وان حسبنا لاختارات المدنيه ستصبح
اكثر من 160 حصلنا على كفالات ضد الاعتقال
في كافه القضايا عبر فريقنا القانوني ما
عدا هذه القضيه سواء في المحاكم العليا او
محاكم البنوك او محكمه قضايا الارهاب او
المحاكم الجنائيه لان كافه القضايا ضد
عمران خان لا اساس لها
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
الذكاء الاصطناعي يصل الى الصحافه وقدراته
تهدد عمل الصحفيين والمذيعين
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه افادت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
بان حاكم ولايه فلوريدا الجمهوريه
رانديسانتوس سيعلن ترشحه لخوض سباق
الرئاسه الامريكيه للعام 2020
لينافس ترامب الذي دعمه حينما كان رئيسا
للولايات المتحده واثار خبر ترشح ديسانتوس
المتوقع تساؤلات بشان طبيعه المنافسه في
الانتخابات التمهيديه لاختيار مرشح الحزب
الجمهوري للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
وبحسب وكالات فرانسبريس انتخب ديسانتوس
بشق الانفس عام 2018 ليكون حاكما لولايه
فلوريدا لكنه منذ ذلك الحين بنفسه عن
الرئيس السابق وزاد من شعبيته من خلال
مواقفه المحافظه على صعيد التربيه والهجره
كما يواجه ديسانتوس في طريقه الى البيت
الابيض العديد من العوائق رغم ان كثيرا من
المحافظين يراهنون عليه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
اليه من هناك مراسل العربيه بيرغانم اهلا
وسهلا بك ما الذي نتوقعهم من مواقف من
ديسانس غدا خصوصا يعني الكلام عن انه
سيصوب جل مواقفه على ترامب
وليس على الديمقراطيين الى هذا الكلام
صحيح
الصحيح هو ان ابي سنتس يتحدث الى
الجمهوريين وهو يريد ان يقول لهم انه
كحاكم لولايه فلوريدا لديه مواقف ولديه
انجازات في قضايا المهاجرين قضايا التربيه
قضايا مواجهه المؤسسات الماليه الكبيره
مثل ديزني وهو نجح في انتخابات التجديد له
باكثر من 60% وبالتالي هو المرشح الحقيقي
الذي يمثل القيم للحزب الجمهوري كل هذا
بالتوازي مع ما هو ترامب ويريد ان يقول
انه لو اراد الجمهوريون بالفعل ان يكون
لديهم مرشح يستطيع ان يكسب الانتخابات
ويكسب اصوات المستقلين فعليهم ان يصوتوا
وليس لدي دونالد تشوب بس هل فعلا انت وفق
متابعتك حتى الاحصاءات هل يشكل ديسانتس
منافسا لدونالد ترامب ام لا يعني هذا
الكلام عليه الكثير من علامات الاستفهام
اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار ان ديسانتوس نجح
بشق الانفس كحاكم لولايه فلوريدا في العام
2018 وبدعم من دون ترامب
الجواب القصير هو لا ليس
تحدي
جديهما الان لدى الجمهوريين ولدا الناخبين
هو عشرين بالمئه ولكن يجب ان ننظر الى ما
فعله ديسمبر وهل يكون هل يكون مرشح جدي ضد
ترامب صحيح انه في المره الاولى نجح بشق
الانفس ولكن في المره الثانيه عندما ترشح
لولايه فلوريدا نجح باكثريه ساحقه اكثر من
60% وبالتالي هو حاكم جدي وناجح وشعبي جدا
الفرق بينه وبين ترامب ان هناك تعلق عاطفي
كبير جدا تجاه شخصيه ترامب لدى الحزب
الجمهوري وليس هناك تعلق عاطفي تجاه
ديسمبر ما يفعله الان هو وضع اله كبيره من
العمليه الانتخابيه لديه تقريبا 200 مليون
دولار وسوف يوظف حوالي الاف شخص في حملته
الانتخابيه وسوف يتوجهون الى الولايات
الاساسيه اي ايوه
وهو سوف يعمل على اقناع الناخبين على انه
هو المرشح الجدي وليس ربط من واشنطن مراسل
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
يتمدد دور الذكاء الاصطناعي ليصل الى
مهنتنا نحن الاعلاميون اذ اصبح هذا الذكاء
قادرا على انتاج الفيديو وكتابه المقالات
وحتى قراءه نشره الاخبار
وبحسب المدير التنفيذي لمجموعه الاعلام
الالمانيه فان الصحفيين معرضون لخطر
استبدالهم بانظمه ذكاء اصطناعي مثل تشاد
جي بي تي وسيكون البرنامج افضل في تجميع
المعلومات من الصحفيين البشر الشركه
المطوره لتشات جي بي تي كشفت ان التحديث
الرابع للروبوت يمكنه من انشاء وتحرير
النصوص ككتابه سيناريوهات او تعلم اسلوب
كتابه المستخدم كما انه متعدد الوسائط
فيمكنه اخراج النص بناء على الصور
يمكنه ايضا اختصار الوقت في عمليه البحث
والوصول الى المعلومه بشكل اسرع كما ان
الروبوت يبسط القضايا المعقده للجمهور مع
سماحه بادخال ملخص او جزء من مقال اكاديمي
لغرض تسهيل وصول المعلومه واخيرا يساعد
الروبوت الذكي في وضع اسئله المقابلات
ونسخ مقابلات سابقه او حتى مقاله كتبها
الشخص الذي تمت مقابلته وتطوير اسئله حول
هذا الموضوع
ما هي نوعيه الاخبار التي تفضلونها لنسمع
ارائكم
ده السياحه الفضائيه هي السفر الى الفضاء
لاغراض ترفيهيه او ترويجيه او مهنيه
تدعمها شركات السياحه الفضائيه رحله
بتكاليف عاليه فكم يبلغ ثمنها
السياحه الفضائيه مفهوم تجاري يفتح افاق
الفضاء امام السياح والزوار ولكن بتكلفه
ليست بالقليله سعر تذكره للذهاب الى
الفضاء يبلغ 55 مليون دولار او ما يعادل
سته ملايين الف دولار في اليوم الواحد
تتضمن التدريب وتخطيط المهمه والدعم الطبي
والبقاء ثمانيه ايام على متن محطه الفضاء
الدوليه تكلفه الطعام الخاص في الفضاء الف
دولار في اليوم الواحد اكياس النوم
والملابس ومنتجات النظافه
1500 دولار في اليوم الواحد تكلفه توصيل
المعدات الى المحطه الفضائيه مقدما 20 الف
دولار للكيلو جرام مع نفس الرسوم للتخلص
منها بعد ذلك
اعلنت السلطات المكسيكيه ان بركان بوب
كاتي بيتول الواقع على بعد 70 كيلومترا
جنوب شرق العاصمه مكسيكو واصل قذف رماد
وغزى وقذف البركان البالغ ارتفاعه
5426 مترا مواد متوهجه تشبه الحمم
البركانيه الحمراء لكن مستوى التحذير من
اخطاره لا يزال على حاله اي اقل بخطوه
واحده من درجه الخطر القصوى
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات